okay so um the plan today was just going
to be to talk about kind of How Shining
actually renders things which is um I
think often we've T sort of thought
about it as like a maybe not exactly an
advanced topic but not something you
would sort of start with right away um
and I think overall it's uh actually
really useful to have like a just better
understanding of the um like how things
actually get rendered and how shiny does
its tricks and this is more important
for python in a lot of ways like this is
what I'm going to talk about is totally
applicable to both R and python they
work exactly the same way um but on the
r side of things like when I was
starting as a shiny developer it was
just kind of like the way that you
developed web applications I didn't
really think about it being a weird way
to develop applications or a magical or
great way of developing them um but it
really is uh so these are slides that
I'm just going to use for um from the
workshop that I gave at uh posit com and
um so this is a little um shiny app here
and if you've kind of used shiny at all
uh you might be familiar with sort of
how like the experience of things
re-rendering so I have these two uh
plots that are both driven by this
slider so there's you know this slider
whenever to make a change both of these
plots reender um but if I change this
slider uh the only plot that renders is
this one so nothing actually happens
with this um with this plot um in the
same way you know if you have a
multi-page um shiny app um the only um
uh the only plot the only uh part of
that um that will uh um that will uh
render the ones that are actually
active um and the question is like how
does shiny do that like how how actually
is is it working um in particular if you
look at this is the python code for that
application that the this is the sort of
total amount of code for the how those
plots are rendered um there's this kind
of weird quality here if you're thinking
about this from from traditional web
development framework which is that um
you know we told shiny what to do but we
didn't tell it when to do it so we
there's no call backs here there's
nothing saying like when this changes in
this way you know fire this function or
anything like that it just kind of knows
and actually seems to usually do a
really really good job at that knowledge
um so how does it work and and maybe
we're thinking like how other Frameworks
work so streamlet has this approach of
rendering everything all the time um
some of these other python Frameworks
like Dash panel and gradio focus more on
like defining a callback function which
is is often referred to as event driven
programming um so what event driven
programming means is that you actually
tell the you're you're the developer
responsible for um telling things when
to fire when to rerender so you're
responding to an event um and it's great
in a lot of ways because it's it's a
very natural way to think like you sort
of are thinking about connecting the
wire from one particular trigger to one
particular output and if you kind of do
that enough times um you can get really
wonderful interactions um but there's a
few different problems with it like one
is you kind of have to do it like it's
it's a little bit more work I think um
it's pretty easy to get wrong especially
if you have something like uh two
elements are both up should be updated
by one call back and you forget to do
one of them you can end up with your
application in this kind of weird State
and it's easy to make those types of
mistakes and most importantly it's
really easy to it's hard to sometimes
hard to tell that you've gotten it wrong
so with like event Ren programming like
a big failure state is just that one of
the numbers in your application is
incorrect or one of the values is
incorrect um rather than getting like a
big loud failure um so those things are
kind of um some of the classic problems
with
them so better way and this is how shiny
does it um is to infer the relationships
between components um and then to build
a computation graph to figure out how
those things should be rendered so when
you if I knew the relationship between
all the different components I could
draw basically a directed a cylic graph
um kind like airflow or something or
make and just update the downstream
elements whenever the Upstream elements
change and I have a really good model
for um being able to um render things
super efficiently and render large
things super
efficiently um so if I kind of you ever
hear somebody tell you that like I have
this magic way of inferring some sort of
thing from your application you know
like check your wallet or something like
it's often um like a little bit of a
Fool's Gold like if you find this
suspicious or don't trust that that's
probably like a good sign um because for
it to work it has to work all the time
like it's not gonna it's not good enough
to just have something like 80% of the
time it gets the right relationship but
sometimes it misses one it needs to be
like really
reliable and we we know this works
because it's worked so well on our side
for so long um you know it's like a long
time of people using this exact pattern
to build um very very complicated
applications that have lasted a long
time um and um the uh sort of underlying
mechanism once you get a handle on it is
it kind of is obvious in some ways and
it's it's easy to to work with um but
one of the things is it's not static
code analysis so this is like one of the
common misconceptions about shiny is
that shiny is actually like reading your
source code and drawing those reactive
links that way um and that's not how
it's working instead it uses something
called runtime tracing
um I just want to give you an example of
why static code analysis wouldn't work
um and the reason is uh there's a bunch
of reasons like one is hard and uh you
know it's like there's a lot of ways you
can get it wrong um but let's say we did
a really really good static code
analyzer to generate stuff there's still
some cases in chiny that it just is
impossible um so this is an example
where um the user is actually um writing
text um that is python code to generate
outputs so it's this is a select thing
but you could easily Imagine This being
a text input um and Chinese is able I'm
able to write an application that
responds to that text um one way of
thinking about this is that the way that
the run the way this application is
running is actually depends not just on
what's In The Source Code but actually
also how the person is using that source
code um so this is the the code that
generates that um and if you're you know
if you're an R user um this you could do
the same thing with some kind of like
you know with with eval as well like you
know if you're doing any kind of meta
programming or anything um on Ru would
run into that uh same situation so you
see here like this is what if we did had
a static code analyzer this is what we
would analyze right we wouldn't be
analyzing what's in the user input
because we don't know what that is right
but this application for it to run
properly actually needs to respond to
that user input and there's a lot of
kind of dynamic uh user interfaces that
you could build with shiny that static
code would
fail um so runtime tracing is a
different strategy and basically what it
is is you just want to ask watch what
all the components ask for and keep
track track of that so whenever somebody
a component runs it's going to ask for
some things if you keep track of those
things um you know that when those
things change that component needs to be
render so basically you just watch for
those components keep track of those
relationships and then build this
computation
graph um so here's a little um example
of some of this so we have um just kind
of highlight with a little code so you
can sort to think of these as like
recipes so there's like a connection
between this output and um this ing
function so this is like text and text
um and there's also a connection between
the uh inputs and the input elements so
this is this is basically this renderer
is saying like um so we know that
basically like when the user opens up
this app and it's asking for the output
of this text uh output um we know that
that's connected they're sort of asking
for this text renderer so we can draw
one link there and then we know that
when this text renderer runs um it's
asking asking for this input n and this
is this can be dynamic right we don't
need to actually look at the code for
that we can sort of keep track of the
component when it's running to see what
it actually is asking
for um so this can give you a little
reactive graph on like this so slider
recipe text um and then I'm just going
to shorten that to be input to
Output um so that's kind of like the the
overall strategy and this kind of leads
this the term for this programming is
this type of programming call it
declarative programming is Whatley calls
it in the shiny book which I think is
really good and so what you're doing is
you're like telling shiny what what
should be generated um but you're not um
but you're trusting that the framework
is going to keep everything up to date
and I just watched the bear which is
this great TV show about menus and so
this is like you're setting the menu
you're not cooking and if you've ever
seen that show there's like um when the
head chef is like in the weeds cooking
yelling yelling very stressful and then
at some point later in the show he
becomes he like gets the restaurant in a
good enough state that he can kind of
like um just handle setting the menu and
and not worry so much about the uh um
the the sort of details right so in this
case like you want this to be you you
want to be this person not this person
right and that's how shiny works it's
expecting you to just tell us what to do
and then trust it to render things
properly um so this is that application
again and uh if we uh think about this
there's like two inputs there's this
slider and this checkbox and then
there's two outputs there's a outputs
there's a plot and a distribution plot
and if you look at it it would look
something like this so you have two
outputs two
inputs um and let me just see the chat
here make sure I'm not missing anything
um and then at the beginning shiny
doesn't know anything about the
relationships between these components
I'll just zoom in a bit that's actually
not gonna work um it doesn't know
anything about the relationships between
these components it just knows that they
exist um and the first thing it does is
it just picks one of these um outputs
and it says let's calculate this output
and when it calculates the output this
is going to ask for checkbox and slider
and Chin is g to watch that and and say
okay last time you ran you asked for
checkbox and slider so I know that you
have a dependency on those time those
two things right now and it's going to
go over to the dis plot and see that the
dis plot only asks for slider doesn't
ask for check checkbox and here we have
um the dag for this application it's a
very very simple dag um but this same
process scales up to kind of an
arbitrarily large number of
nodes okay so what happens when a slider
changes so when the slider changes we
know that there's a dependency here so
we can follow those down and say these
two things need to are called
invalidated so they need to be re
recalculated and then um it forgets all
the dependencies that goes into it says
okay whatever I knew in the past might
not be true anymore so I'm just going to
totally forget about it um and then it
recalculates in this case it generates
the same graph but it doesn't have to it
could generate a different graph
depending on your application like at
runtime it's it's sort of on the Fly
figuring out all those relationships
based on what things have asked for
what okay so then everything's updated
um if we ask for the checkbox we change
the checkbox does the same thing it
follows this down says oh there's a
scatter plot there last time we ran that
asked for the scatter plot so that's
going to be out of date need to rerun
the scatter plot
renderer um so I'm going to forget the
dependencies from the scatter plot but I
don't since I'm since this disc plot is
fine F I don't need to change any of
those things I don't need to do anything
with this one so I'm going to leave that
part of theph
intact um then it's going to recalculate
it's going to get both of its values and
then we're up to
date um are there any questions about
that okay so way clearer than I thought
I was G than I thought I was being I
guess or way less clear not sure uh so
the great thing about this is that uh
this is a pattern that scales really
well so a lot of um the other python web
application Frameworks they actually
usually have like several patterns
embedded in them for different levels of
app complexity so you write um you know
a Dash app one way for when you're doing
a simple application and then another
way when you're using a more complicated
one you might be using much more caching
or something like that um you might
write a streamlet app in one way at the
beginning and then over time you need to
kind of manage State uh yourself um and
I think similarly for all of them panel
has three different basically like apis
for updating different components um but
for shiny every app uses the same exact
pattern so when you kind of understand
how this works at this little toy level
that we were talking about you actually
are really far along understanding it at
a much larger
level um it works for dynamic AIS and
it's also uis and it's also lazy so
that's kind of one of the reasons why um
some chiny apps can be so efficient
because if um if we're back here right
this is only because the user is trying
to ask for this so if the user actually
is not asking for scatter plot like it's
not on the screen that it's on a
background tab or something like that um
shiny just doesn't get around to
calculating it never bothers to it only
does that when it actually needs to or
if you were the developer like say it
needs to recalculate all the
time um so that kind of leads to these
types of efficient things um but where
we're at now is like just with what
would you call like flat reactive graphs
where they all go input to Output um and
there's another
pattern that adds a lot of depth to this
thing which is reactive calculations or
in our reactive
Expressions um so um so The Decorator in
in Python is reactive calc um and it
basically like creates calculations that
whose results can be used by other
renderers so it's not rendering itself
it's something that you're going to be
able to pass on you could think of it
just like a reactive
variable uh so here's an example um so
this is a an application this is again a
kind of silly toy application where we
have a one table and we have a uh a plot
of some random data and you know up here
this kind of looks fine but if I just s
of test it a little bit and say I
produce like three
values um you know maybe like few more
values you see we have like
um some of these are not actually uh uh
oh maybe I've actually yeah so this is a
good example so see here I have like
0.13 and 0.12 two but over here on the
plot I have 08 and point and basically
zero so like what's going on like why
these should these are different and
that's like a very confusing user
experience um and the reason they're
different is because I'm actually taking
the sample twice so this is the code for
that application and I have basically in
the renderer this NP random Rand so this
is a numpy function that takes a random
sample and this is being produced here
and it's being produced here so these
are going to be different right because
every time I do this thing it's going to
take a new the whole point of that
function is it takes a new sample and
this is kind of what that application
looks like I have this one slider that's
changing and I have sample and table
over here and Sample and blood over here
and they're not going to be the
same um so this is both um there's a lot
of problems with this code um and uh in
this case it's in defined in multiple
places so I have to change it in
multiple places um the big problem is
it's taking the sample twice so it's not
the same right and that's going to cause
me a lot of headaches if I'm trying to
like build up intuition about how this
sample works
um and and they're not using the same
sample so there's an so if you use a
reactive calculation what you do or
reactive expression in R um is you take
that code and you define it in um a
function and you decorate that function
with reactive calc and then when you're
using it in your renderers you refer to
that function uh down here so you're not
actually taking the random sample there
you're referring to this
bundle and um if this is a a regular
function that would just result in this
same behavior right it would run through
these things every time it was called
but a reactive function uh the first
time it runs it caches its value and
then returns that cach value uh instead
of
rerunning
um and the main sort of thing that it
does is adds nodes to this reactive
graph so I'll just show this to you in a
in a in a picture because it's it's a
lot easier so this is kind of like again
shiny starts out here with this this
table with this reactive calculation and
it doesn't know the relationship between
any of these things I'm putting this
hierarchical but it doesn't even know
that it's hierarchical it just knows
their things um so table runs and when
table runs it calls the sample reactive
calculation and then you run through the
sample reactive calculation and it says
oh I need slider it goes out and gets
slider and then shiny has the
relationship between these three things
uh when the plot tries to render it goes
and tries to get sample but since sample
is a valid um reactive it hasn't been
invalidated it's shiny knows that it's
correct right slider hasn't changed
since the last time sample
um it just Returns the old value for
plot so this makes it really good for
some of these situations of sampling
where you need to make sure that it's
only to happening once but it's also
great for just reducing compli
computation so this could be a long
running model step or a database query
or something like that and it would sort
of automatically perfectly cache the
results um for
you uh so then we have a deep a deep
reactive graph and these things can be
stacked on top of each other you don't
need to have just one layer of
reactivity of reactives you could have
as many you want um so when the slider
changes it does the exact same process
so it follows that down it says okay
sample invalidated and since we're now
in like a deep reactive graph sample has
to do one more thing which is or it has
to do one more thing which is like tell
all the downstream things to invalidate
as well and so it does that and then
everything's invalidated and then it
does it again so it goes to the table
gets the sample sample runs goes and
gets the slider plot runs and so forth
and then we have our updated
graph and um that's the end of what I
was going to talk about today so I think
that's kind of like the basic idea of
how um reactivity works for uh um for uh
both shiny for R and shiny for Python
and I think we kind of Master those
little like small things as your app
grows you can kind of run into some bugs
where really what's happening is you're
usually you're trying to use an event
driven pattern for when you should be
using a reactive one um but also just
helps you debug and figure out like why
is that not rendering you know it's
probably because there's some some sort
of uh uh so one of these things is being
detected in an unexpected
way so a question from Amed are there
limitations on the number of
intermediate calculations Allowed by
shiny no um and this is one of the great
things about it is that you can have as
many of these as you want um I would say
that there I mean there are limitations
just the more calculations you do the
slower your app is going to be but for
the most part um so long as you're like
following like a non like do not repeat
yourself you can have as many of them as
you want like the having something in a
reactive calculation is the most
efficient way that shiny can render it
so that's your best strategy rather than
having logic um sort of uh split across
renderers or anything like
that um so it's pretty hard so the
question uh from uh um from Paul what
happens when your graph uh contains
Cycles um so there is a
function um which is
uh like so you're not it causes a crash
right because it's like it doesn't know
how to how to update things um there's a
function um show the screen
[Music]
again uh so there's a way of of uh kind
of starting to so this is kind of like
the basics of reactivity um there's a
lot of ways of managing it manually um
so one of them is
um
uh
sorry reactive isolate um so reactive
isolate is basically a way of like
getting the value of a of a re of
reactive of an input or reactive without
drawing that reactive link so this is
kind of like if you ever end up in a
place where you do have a cyclical graph
usually like adding and reactive isolate
just breaks one part of that to get out
of that pattern um the other way that
you can work the other thing that's
handy is um this function this decorator
called reactive event um which basically
is a way of manually drawing one of
those things and saying like only react
to this one thing and not anything else
that I might be
calling um so that we do have patterns
for avoiding that but yeah you can't
you're not allowed to have it'll cause a
a crash whenever you uh have a circular
gr dependency like
that um any other questions or we could
also talk about uh other
things ah okay I do have the answer this
is uh from uh from Kelvin when will the
shiny package get its next B up update
and what will be in it uh should be soon
I don't know exactly when we're doing
the release maybe this week um this week
or next week the main thing that's
happening there is we've had these um
components in this experimental section
over here um just while we were kind of
sorting out some of the um like some of
the one of one of our goals is we want
to have like the RN python packages like
reused as much of the same code as we
can so that we can make sure that when
we're developing something for R it
comes to python quickly and vice versa
so we had a lot of conversations about
how to do that um and we' we're done
with those we're able to bring over
basically all of these experimental uh
things into the main package which makes
you a lot easier to like use them um so
that's the main thing that's coming um
next uh in this release I think it's the
the sort of mostly what's in there and
then um yeah we have some um other
things around I think tables is our next
main thing thing we're going to keep
working on as well as making the sort of
like really
early um user experience of building
shiny apps easier uh to kind of like
simplify um some of this stuff like we
have we've s gotten some feedback where
it's like they like shiny for
complicated things but for simple things
there's a little bit too much boiler
plate um too many decorators you know so
trying to figure out how to simplify
that but that'll probably not be next
release but the one after but we should
have a October release up
soon